émerveillé intimider fasciné c'est un
torrent d'émotions qui traverse ces
jeunes footballeur à l'heure de
rencontrer une de leur idole qui en rêve
depuis que je suis tout petit de
rencontrer monsieur raphaël varane et
j'ai réalisé mon rêve et là je suis
extrêmement content ça fait content de
voir qu'il ya des joueurs qui jouent en
club peau ici en matière culturelle va y
passer un bon défenseur de la ligue ou
beaucoup ça fait content de le voir ici
de faire des photos avec lui le champion
du monde où le jeu et répond aux
questions de tous les élèves des centres
de perfectionnement
ça me fait plaisir c'est bien pour pour
les jeunes martiniquais martiniquaise de
de pouvoir me rencontrer moi ça me fait
plaisir de les voir évoluer sur le
terrain tu d'échangés aussi un peu avec
eux ils sont heureux de me voir ils sont
de bonne humeur et font des petites
blagues il peut faire une photo me voir
donc c'est bien je suis venu aussi pour
ça et des six jeunes pour aller vers
l'excellence nécessite la mise en place
d'infrastructures et de programmes
adaptés
il faut que ce soit des entraîneurs de
haut niveau spécialisé dans la formation
du jeune footballeur il faut qu'il y ait
un encadrement médical suivi médical qui
soit véritablement opérationnel il faut
qu'il ya des terrains d'entraînement qui
permettent aux jeunes d'être dans des
meilleures conditions
il faut qu'il y ait des conditions
d'hébergement qu'ils soient respectés
avec une alimentation adaptée
et puis il faut qu'il y ait de la
compétition parce que nous sommes
victimes de notre isolement et de notre
insularité et par conséquent nous
pêchons un peu dans ce domaine une
démarche pour laquelle raphaël varane
est prêt à mouiller le maillot pour
l'instant on fait des stages de foot
ouvert à tous garçons filles pour quels
que soient les niveaux aussi pour
progresser pour apprendre beaucoup de
choses sur le terrain et en dehors
et puis j'ai encore pas mal d'idées en
tête pour pour continuer à apporter
quelque chose aux jeunes ici et dans la
joie et la bonne humeur le champion du
monde a donné le coup d'envoi du match
final de la compétition